14 24 l'heure est au bilan dans ce
supermarché de fontenay-le-fleury romain
et bertrand de créer cogérant contre les
produits lactalis retirés des rayons et
détruit total de l'inventaire 99 boîte
sur onze référence des boîtes de lait en
poudre soupçonnés d'être contaminés à la
salmonelle des destructions suite aux
alertes envoyées par le fournisseur
depuis le 21 décembre dernier
tous les employés du magasin ont accès à
ces informations
je vais dessus et on avance et nier ce
qu'on avait nous en magasin le nom du vc
et on a accusé bien sûr la destruction
des produits
on attend donc jusqu'au 21 janvier dont
autour de nos clients pour savoir s'il
ya des clients qui ont acheté ce produit
là maintenant à savoir si dans notre
stock qu'on avait physiquement magasin
il y avait un risque microbien ou pas de
salmonelle sa relance est rien et on n'a
aucun moyen de savoir
l'approvisionnement des produits
lactalis a aussi été bloquées en clair
le magasin ne peut plus commander les
boîtes de lait concernés par la
contamination des informations aux
consommateurs sont aussi affichés à
l'accueil du magasin et dans le rayon à
l'emplacement habituel des produits
retirés
donc c'est tous les lots concernés qui
pourraient présenter un cas de
salmonelle on voit la formation qu'on a
mis d'entrée disposition du consommateur
donc on a imprimé qui est la même qu'on
voit là ya l'accueil expliquant donc la
procédure à suivre pour le consommateur
qui auraient pu acheter
ce lait lactalis donc avant le 21
décembre
mauvais étiquetage produits défectueux
plusieurs raisons pour retirer ou
détruire un produit en moyenne ce
magasin reçoit une alerte par jour